you have of many papers but
the one that caught my eyes smooth
analysis of dynamic networks
in which you write a problem with the
worst case perspective is that it often
leads to extremely strong lower bounds
these strong results motivate a key
question is this bond robust
in the sense that it captures the
fundamental difficulty introduced by
dynamism
or is the bond fragile in the sense that
the poor performance it describes
depends on an exact sequence
of adversarial changes fragile lower
bounds
leave open the possibility of algorithms
that might still perform well in
practice
that's a in the sense of the impossible
and the balance discussion presents the
interesting question
i just like the idea of robust and
fragile bounds
but uh what do you make about this kind
of
tension between what's provably like
what the what bounds you can prove
that are like robust and something
that's a bit more fragile
and and also by way of answering that
for this particular paper
uh can you say what the hell are dynamic
networks
what are the distributors i don't know
this come on now and i have no idea and
what is smooth analysis yeah well okay
so
so smooth analysis it's so it wasn't my
idea so spielman and tang
came up with this in the context of
sequential algorithms just like
the normal world of an algorithm that
runs on a computer and they were they
were looking at
there's a well-known algorithm called
the simplex algorithm but basically
you're
trying to whatever find a hole around a
group of points there's an algorithm
that worked really well in practice
but when you analyze it you would say
you know i can't guarantee it's going to
work well in practice because if you
have just the right
inputs this thing could run really long
right but in practice it seemed to be
really fast so
smooth analysis as they came in and they
said let's assume that
a bad guy chooses the inputs it could be
anything like really bad ones
and all we're going to do is because and
simplex they're numbers
we're going to just randomly put a
little bit of noise on each of the
numbers
and they said if you put a little bit of
noise on the numbers suddenly simplex
algorithm goes really fast like oh that
explains this lower bound
this idea that it could sometimes run
really long was a fragile bound because
it could only run a really long time if
you had
exactly the worst pathological input so
then my collaborators and i brought this
over to the world of distributed
algorithms
we brought them over the general lower
bounds right so so in the world of
dynamic networks
so distributed algorithm is a bunch of
algorithms on different machines talking
to each other
trying to solve a problem and sometimes
they're in a network so you imagine them
connected with network links
and a dynamic network those can change
right so i was talking to you but now i
can't talk to you anymore and i'm
connected to a person over here
it's a really hard environment
mathematically speaking and there's a
lot of really strong lower bounds which
you could imagine if the network can
change all the time
and a bad guy's doing it it's like hard
to do things well so there's an
algorithm
running on every single node in the
network yeah and then you're trying to
say
something of any kind that makes any
kind of definitive sense about the
performance of that algorithm yeah so
like uh we're
so i just submitted a new paper on this
a couple weeks ago and we were looking
at a very simple problem there's
there's a some messages in the network
we want everyone to get them
if the network doesn't change you can do
this pretty well
you can pipeline them there's some
algorithms that work basic algorithms
that work really well
if network can change every round
there's these lower bounds
that says uh it takes a really long time
there's a way that like no matter what
algorithm you come up with there's a way
the network can change in such a way
that just
really slows down your progress
basically right so smooth analysis there
says yeah but that seems like a
really you know really bad luck if your
network was changing like exactly
in the right way that you needed to
screw your algorithm so we said what if
we uh
randomly just add or remove a couple
edges in every round so the adversary's
trying to choose the worst possible
network we're just
tweaking it a little bit and in that
case this is a new paper i mean
it's a blind submission so maybe i
shouldn't it's not whatever
um we basically showed uh an anonymous
friend of yours submitted a paper
anonymous friend of mine yeah
yeah whose paper should be accepted so
that even just adding like one random
edge per round
you uh the here's the cool thing about
the simplest possible solution to this
problem
blows away that lower bound it does
really well so that's like a very
fragile lower bound because we're like
it's it
it's almost impossible to actually
keep things slow i wonder how many lower
bounds you can smash
open with this kind of analysis and show
that they're fragile
it's my interest yeah because in
distributed algorithms
there's a ton of really famous strong
lower bounds but things have to go wrong
really really wrong uh for these lower
bound arguments to work
and so i like this approach so this this
whole notion of fragile verse robust i
was like
let's go in and just throw a little
noise in there and if it becomes
solvable
then maybe that lower bound wasn't
really something we should worry about
you know
that's gonna embarrass that's really
uncomfortable that's really embarrassing
to a lot of people because okay this is
the ocd thing with the
the spaces is it feels really good when
you can prove a nice bound
and uh if you say that that bond is
fragile
yeah that that's that's like there's
going to be a sad kid that walks
uh like with their lunch box back home
like yeah
my my lower bond doesn't matter no i
don't think they care it's all
and i don't know it feels like to me a
lot of this theory is just math much
easier
yeah it's like whatever this was a hard
bound to prove yeah do you what do you
think about that like uh so if you show
that something is fragile that's more
important
that's really important for in practice
right uh
so do you think kind of theoretical
computer science is living its own world
just like mathematics
yeah and their main effort which i think
is very valuable is to develop ideas
it's not necessarily
interesting whether it's applicable in
the real world yeah we don't care about
the applicability
yeah we kind of do but not really and
we're terrible with computers
and can't do anything useful with
computers we don't know how to code and
and
you know we're not we're not productive
members of like technological society
but
i do think things percolate exactly you
percolate from the the world of theory
into the world of algorithm design which
will pull on the theory and now suddenly
it's useful
uh and then the algorithm design gets
pulled into the world of practice where
they say well actually we can make this
algorithm a lot better because in
practice really these servers do xyz and
now we can make this super efficient
and so i do think i mean i tell my i
teach theory to the phd students at
georgetown
i show them the sort of funnel of like
okay we're over here doing theory but
eventually some of this stuff will
percolate down in effect
at the very end you know a phone but
it's a long
it's a long tunnel but the very question
you're asking
at the the highest philosophical level
is fascinating like if you take a system
a distributed system
or a network and introduced a little bit
of noise
into it like how many problems of that
nature
are fundamentally changed by that little
introduction of noise
yeah because it's all especially in
distributed algorithms the model is
everything like the way we work is we're
incredibly precise about here's exactly
it's mathematical here's exactly how the
network works and it's a state machine
algorithms are state machines there's
rounds and schedulers we're super
precise we can prove lower bounds
but yeah often there's lower those
impossibility results really
get at the hard edges of exactly how
that model works so we'll we'll see if
this guy
so we we published a paper on this that
paper you mentioned
um that kind of introduced the idea to
the distributed algorithms world and i
think
that's got some traction and there's
been some follow-ups and we've just
submitted our
uh our next honestly the issue with the
next is that like the result fell out so
easily
and this is just a mathematical machismo
problem these in these fields is
there's a good chance the paper won't be
accepted because there wasn't enough
mathematical self-flagellation that's
such a nice finding
so even showing that very few just very
little bit of noise
yeah gonna have a dramatic uh make a
dramatic statement about uh
it was a big surprise to us but um once
we figured out how to show it
it's not too hard and these are these
are venues that for theoretical
yeah theoretical well okay so the the
fascinating tension that exists in other
disciplines like one of them is machine
learning
now which it despite the the power of
machine learning and deep learning and
all like the impact of it
in the real world the main conferences
on machine learning
are still resistant to application
papers
i'm not uh sort of and application paper
is broadly defined
meaning like finding
almost like you would like darwin did by
like
uh going around collecting some
information saying huh isn't this
interesting
yeah uh like those are some of the most
popular blogs
and yet as the paper it's not really
accepted
you